imagine an enormous football stranded in
the solar system I mean the earth shaped
like one what could cause our planet to
change its shape so drastically what
would it mean for all the life
inhabiting it this is what if and here's
what would happen if the earth was
shaped like a football an American
football if you thought the earth was
round you worked exactly right and if by
any chance you thought it was flat you
were definitely wrong the true shape of
Earth is called an oblate spheroid it's
a sphere that's squashed at the poles so
that the equator sticks out a bit
although most planets are oblate
spheroids there are some oddly shaped
cosmic objects out there one of Saturn's
moons Prometheus for one resembles a
potato and this comet looks like a
rubber duck and then there's an
exoplanet shaped exactly like an
American football imagine if our earth
was shaped like that
well it wouldn't be good for us
that football shaped planet is called
wasp 121 B and the reason why it has a
shape like that is because of its very
close proximity to its star the
gravitational tidal forces of That star
affect the planet unevenly stretching it
at the equator and because the star and
the planet are so close the planets
upper atmosphere reaches 25,000 degrees
that's roughly half the temperature of
our Sun yeah wasp 121 B is ridiculously
high you definitely wouldn't want earth
to switch places with it but how about
we move our planet closer to our Sun
would that be enough to reshape the
earth like that
well Earth orbits the Sun at a safe
distance of 150 million kilometers
scientists call this distance one
astronomical unit toward a you move the
earth a few million kilometers closer
and it would get very hot on our planet
for example if we moved our planet into
the orbit of Venus the Sun would be
hitting us with 92 percent more solar
energy the earth wouldn't get scorching
hot immediately first the increased
brightness would cause a runaway
greenhouse effect
all our glaciers would melt and poison
our atmosphere with elevated methane
levels
the sea levels would rise and force
people to relocate from the flooded
coasts then the increased sea area will
cause even more heat absorption raising
the temperatures of our oceans even more
as the greenhouse gases were building up
our planet would be heating up to
temperatures of Venus we're talking
surface temperatures as high as 462
degrees and as you might guess no life
could ever inhabit a planet that hot
right but what if the earth got to keep
the shape of a football - the extreme
heat then life would still go on but it
would be a little different for one
thing the earth might have to rotate
faster in order to keep that shape a day
on earth might become as short as only a
few hours secondly gravity wouldn't be
distributed evenly throughout the planet
the poles would have lower gravity while
gravitational pull at the equator would
be stronger this is because there be
more mass around the equator other than
that life would go on we just keep
inhabiting a football shaped planet and
maybe it had solve that age-old argument
between the Brits and the Yanks on whose
football is better if the earth were to
change its shape I'd rather it be in the
shape of a doughnut but that's a story
for another
what if
you